okay I mentioned we would talk about
this we haven't had time this week we
have time today and I'm not going to
spend a ton of time on it but the CPAC
straw poll uh every CPAC which is
sometimes more frequently than we might
assume
um at every CPAC there's something
called a straw poll a straw poll is a
vote of those at CPAC who do we want to
see be the Republican nominee or Vice
Presidential nominee now on the bonus
show we already talked about how Kerry
Lake came easily in first place in terms
of who the CPAC attendees wanted to have
as the Vice Presidential nominee the
other bit of this is that
um in the regular straw poll Donald
Trump easily won very very easily won
and in fact DeSantis lost by 42 points
uh there is an article from the hill
Trump easily wins CPAC poll former
president Trump easily easily won the
straw poll Trump won with 62 percent
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis likely his
closest rival came in at 20
62-20 that's plus 42 for Trump
businessman Perry Johnson who announced
his candidacy this week got five percent
I have to be honest I don't even know
who that is I didn't even know about
that I have no clue what the deal is uh
with Perry Johnson Trump won last year's
straw poll in CPAC with 59 and DeSantis
28. so last year Trump was plus 31 over
DeSantis and now Trump is plus 42. now a
few important things to talk about first
and foremost do CPAC straw polls reflect
Republican primary voters not really
in the sense that there's a lot of
people like listen if you're a Mitt
Romney Republican
in Utah or maybe Massachusetts where
Romney was previously governor and you
kind of want lower taxes and less
business regulation but you're sort of
like pretty reasonable when it comes to
social issues you're not going to CPAC
at all so your vote you're not even part
of this entire thing and when we look at
actual polling what we find is that it's
definitely closer a new morning consult
poll that includes a whole bunch of
different candidates has Trump plus 25
still a very big lead but it is not 42.
um there is a uh uh Emerson College poll
which does have Trump plus 41 but other
than that it's much smaller leads
everything from Trump plus eight all the
way down to actually DeSantis even being
ahead in some polling so is Trump
winning the Republican primary right now
absolutely there's no there's no doubt I
don't think there is any if you look at
the only way you can make the case that
Trump isn't winning is by saying we are
only going to pay attention to like the
Susquehanna poll and that's not a good
methodology we're either looking at an
average of polls or we're looking at all
a rated pollsters or whatever but to
just say based on this one poll that's a
mediocre poll Trump is not winning
doesn't seem accurate so Trump is
absolutely winning right now can it
change sure the other aspect to the
primary uh to the rather CPAC poll that
I think is very very interesting is that
Republican candidate Vivek ramaswamy who
is getting very little support he said
to Stuart Varney on Fox Business that
you can just pay to rig the CPAC straw
poll very interesting claim take a
listen to this is this trumped GOP
I think that the America First agenda
the people who are behind America First
are really committed to putting America
First not Trump first not Vivek first
it's America First and what I saw there
I mean I gave a speech we got five
standing ovations in the middle of the
speech there's a little funny little
secret I learned a steward well you're
not going to get five standing ovations
at the end you you would only get one at
the end so it makes sense they were in
the middle I'm new to this as an
outsider one of the things you see as an
outsider is how corrupt this system is
you know something funny about this I've
attended CPAC before I didn't know it
works this way a consultant calls my
campaign shortly after I declare and
says hey we can get you up to number two
on there if you pay a few hundred
thousand dollars really I was shocked
you know and I mean you know what
there's a lot of people who are making
money oh not only off of me but off of
every presidential campaign this will
probably be not only the most expensive
presidential campaign the one that
people in the industry it's politics and
Industry people make so much money off
of this that one of the things I'm going
to be doing throughout this campaign is
exposing it because you know what I
didn't get to where I am by actually
just getting exploited and I think the
American people actually deserve to see
the sausage getting made did you pay so
absolutely not I mean that is fake so
why would if he paid he got ripped off
he got like zero or something they get
bumped up one over two no I said I would
take my speaking I said I would take my
speaking slot instead and actually you
can people can see that speech on my
website
vivek2024.com see the speech and see the
crowd's reaction and I think people
should be the judge of what's really
going on now earlier we talked about the
Kerry Lake story Kerry Lake says someone
came to her house and said ma'am I'll
give you a bunch of money and a job to
get out of politics I tend not to
believe that that happened do I believe
what Vivek ramaswamy uh uh is claiming
actually took place that he was offered
the opportunity to pay to get himself
the second slot
I kind of do
um I at least am open to it why because
there is already a sort of pay to play
Scandal involving the American
conservative Union which is um the
organizer of CPAC involving a guy named
Brian Kelsey this guy Matt schlapp who
runs the uh runs CPAC is is a shady guy
to say the least so I am much if you say
to me David do you think that Carrie
Lake's story is the most likely story to
be true or Vivek ramaswami's story is
the most likely to be true true I think
the Rama Swami story is much much much
more likely to be true where will the
polling be in three months in six months
absolutely no idea we're going to follow
it we're going to watch it it's a new
year many of us are trying to make new
positive changes here's something really
simple that could be a game changer our
sponsor athletic greens every day I take
a scoop of ag-1 I get 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients to last me all day long this
way I just know my nutritional bases are
covered for the entire day it has
everything I want and that's important
to me rather than doing the individual
supplements and vitamins or whatever
I don't want to do any of that okay ag1
is the simplest way to just get
everything I want for my nutritional
Foundation each day ag1 is also a great
bang for your buck you're going to end
up spending way more on all those
bottles of vitamins and supplements and
minerals so save some money make your
life easier just a scoop of ag1 I love
the travel packs which let me take ag1
wherever I go I have the big pack of
ag-1 at home and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get
five free travel packs plus a free year
supply of vitamin D which I use during
the winter the link is down below